you're standing at a traffic
intersection and you start to accelerate
when the light turns green suppose that
your acceleration as a function of time
is a constant for some time interval T
less than T 1 and after that at 0 for
time after T 1 less than T less than
some time T 2 at the exact same instant
the light turns green a bicyclist is
coming through the intersection and the
bicyclist is has some initial speed and
is breaking with an acceleration of
minus B 2 for the entire time interval T
T 2 and at time T 2 the bicyclist comes
to rest exactly where you are located
and we also know some initial conditions
so our initial conditions in this
problem are that you're accelerating b1
at a rate 2 meters per second squared
and you do this for time t1 equals one
second and the bicyclist comes into the
intersection we'll call that B 2 not
that's the initial speed of the
bicyclist at 3 meters per second and the
question is what is the rate of
deceleration of the bicycle as B 2 now
this is can be quite a complicated
problem so the first thing we want to do
is just make a sketch and think about
what's involved this problem involves
two objects you and the bicyclist the
person that's you has two stages of
motion
and the bicyclists only has one stage of
motion so to get started it always helps
to choose a coordinate system and to
make some sketches of the problem so
let's say we choose a it's all one
dimensional motion two objects one
dimensional motion and so we'll pick an
origin at the light at the one side of
the intersection and we have two objects
which we'll talk about you x1 and the
bicycle is x2 actually we don't know yet
who's in front of the other the bicycles
will be first in front of you so now how
do we sketch the motion of these two
stages of motions so let's make a sketch
and let's start with the person well the
person if we plotted their position as a
function of time this will be positioned
in general I'll just draw the person
function they're accelerating to a time
t1 and then they're moving at a constant
speed at time t2 now the bicyclists a
little more complicated because
initially the bicyclist has a this is at
time T person 1 initially the bicyclist
has a nonzero slope and they're
decelerating and they reach you with the
zero slope so this graph this is the X 2
that is the bicyclist and right here we
have the person x1 so now to build a
strategy we have we can even look at our
graph and see that from our initial
conditions we have some special
conditions that the so from our strategy
will be to 1 figure out what this time
is and we know that the bicyclist
at time t2 has come to a stop so that's
one condition
and we also know that the bicyclist
comes to a stop exactly at the same
position as the person X 1 T 2 equals X
2 of T 2 so those are two conditions
that we can deduce from all of this
given information and now we can apply
our kinematic relationships for both the
bicyclist and the person and try to see
if these conditions will enable us to
deduce what B 2 is so let's begin with
the bicyclist so the velocity of the
bicyclist as a function of time is
simply the integration of that bicyclist
DT Prime from zero to T 2 this is one
stage of motion the acceleration is
minus B 2 so this is a very
straightforward integral this is just B
of 2t 2 V 2 this is minus the initial
speed equals that B of T 2 minus V of
the initial is that and because we want
this to be 0 we have the condition that
T 2 equals V 2 naught divided by B 2 so
that's our first condition for the
bicyclist now we have to separately
solve for the bicyclist position that's
easy x2 of T is the integral of V 2 T
prime DT Prime from 0 to t 2 and that's
just minus 1/2 this is we want to make
sure that we get the displacement but at
x2 naught is 0 so we have X 2 at T 2
equals
the loss integral of the velocity
function which is v2 naught minus B 2 of
T prime DT Prime from 0 to T 2 and so we
get v2 naught T 2 minus 1/2 B 2 t2
squared and when we input this condition
in for T 2 this becomes very simply it
becomes v2 naught squared over 2 B 2
substituting T 2 into each of these
expressions gives us that relationship
so that's the position of the cycle of
the cyclists at time T 2 now this is a
little bit trickier to get the position
of the person so in order to do that we
first find the velocity of the person
function it's a two-stage motion so for
the first stage of motion the velocity 2
velocity of person 1 minus their initial
velocity which is 0 minus 1 0 that's 0
equals the integral of B 1 DT prime from
0 to t1 which is just B 1 t1
and this velocity remains constant
throughout the next interval so we can
write the velocity function in the
following way V 1 T equals V 1 T for 0
less than T less than T 1 and afterwards
a constant velocity now
this is the function that we need to
integrate to get the displacement so
let's get ourselves a little room here
and integrate that and we have X of T is
two integrals first from 0 to T 1 the
velocity function during that time
interval and then for the second time
interval DT 2 the velocity function is
constant B this is B 1 B 1 T 1 DT prime
notice this is not a variable but it is
the time at the end of the interval and
when we make these two integrals we get
1/2 B 1 T 1 squared let's make this the
velocity at time no that's time T this
first integral goes from 0 to T 1 and
the second interval we're gonna make
this the position at time t 2 and we get
plus B 1 times T 1 times T 2 minus T 1
we have a common term T 1 squared B 1/2
B 1 T 1 squared B 1 minus B 1 t 1
squared so this reduces to one-half v1
t1 squared plus B 1 t1 t2 and that's how
we find the position of the person for
our interval let's just review that to
make sure because we had to get the
velocity function first and then we
integrated the velocity in each time
interval correctly you know
to get the position function now we can
apply our conditions notice we already
know t2 here and we can now apply the
second condition which says that the
position of the bicyclist at time t2
which we found to be V naught squared
over 2 B 2 is equal to the position of
the cyclists of the person at that same
time so that's minus one-half v1 t1
squared plus B 1 t1 now let's make that
substitution for time T 2 so that's V 2
naught over B 2 and now our problem is
to solve for this time B 2 and we're
given B 1 we're given T 1 we're given V
2 naught and the only variable here is B
2 it's a little bit of algebra to
rearrange terms what I'll do is I'll
bring this term over to here so now
we'll just do a little bit of algebra we
have a B 2 I pull out I have a minus B 1
t 1 v2 dot and that's equal to minus
one-half v1 t1 squared and now I can
solve for B 2 and so I get B 2 is equal
to V T naught squared minus B 1 T 1 B 2
not over minus one-half v1 t1 squared
now let's just do a quick dimensional
check B times T has the dimensions of
velocity so this is velocity square
velocity squared that's okay upstairs B
times T squared is dimensions of
position so what we have is meters
squared per second squared divided by
meters
that gives us meters per second squared
so we're pretty confident that we're at
least didn't make an algebraic mistake
and now our last step is to substitute
in the numbers and what we get is if we
put in the three meters a second squared
minus B 1 times T 1 times 3
so we get upstairs is minus three-halves
and downstairs is two times one second
twos cancel so we get 4b to three-halves
meters per second squared when we put in
the numbers if we want to check our
result we can then see what time we get
T two is nine is T two is three meters
per second divided by our B 2 which is
three-halves meters per second squared
so that's two seconds and now the last
check would be to see that the position
functions correspond to that let's see
if we can just do that quickly in our
heads our position function for the
person is V naught squared over to be 2
so that's
9 meters per second 9 meters squared
second squared over 2 times 3 halves
meters second squared and that comes out
to x2 of T this is a check is 3 meters
and the x1 of T we've left out the 1
there we should have had it it's a
little more complicated to put in here
but we'll just run the numbers quickly
through 2 times 1 seconds - that's a
minus 1/2 times 1 times 2 that's 2 times
2 so this is also 3 meters and we
actually have the right answer here